أجرى [موسيقى]
Flying Scotsman الأجنبية للتو
إصلاحًا شاملًا بحيث يكون مناسبًا للتشغيل وأنت
تعلم أن أجزاء منه عمرها 100 عام تبلى ،
لذا انتهى الأمر قبل يومين
من الإصلاح وهو الآن في
أفضل حالة
إنه رمز تصميم إنه  رمز للأناقة
كان موجودًا في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لقد ذهب إلى
أستراليا ، لقد كان في أمريكا ،
كان أول محرك يعمل بسرعة 100 ميل في
الساعة أو رسميًا يبدو رائعًا ،
إنه آلة أنيقة
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
السكك الحديدية في  يؤدي الاستخدام الرائع
للقطارات إلى زيادة عدد الركاب
أكثر من أي وقت مضى في تاريخ السكك الحديدية
[موسيقى]
يمكنك أن تحبها على العديد من
المستويات المختلفة سواء كنت مهندسًا
ومؤرخًا ومصممًا أو مجرد
شخص لديه ذاكرة مغرمة
مجموعة قطار
[موسيقى]
رائعة لأنها هنا جنبًا إلى جنب مع
السكك الحديدية الحديثة ، القطارات عالية السرعة التي
تحمل قطارات هيتاشي من
لندن أو هيوستن للسكك الحديدية
الأجنبية